welp Donald Trump's been cooked again
this time by the US Senate shockingly
doing something right for once I can't
even say it seriously and I know people
write it in this day David you know you
shouldn't use that word
I'm ridiculing the use of the word when
I say it I hope people understand I'm
undecided on the use of that word so far
fair enough
as we know Donald Trump's administration
started working on easing sanctions
against Russia within hours of Donald
Trump being sworn in on January 20th and
really even before January 20th
unofficially as we have since learned
through such events as the resignation
and shame of former national security
adviser Mike Flynn the Senate is going
against the Trump administration's
attempt to ease Russian sanctions
they've overwhelmingly voted for a new
set of sanctions against Russia
specifically to punish them for
interfering in the 2016 election they
voted overwhelmingly but not unanimously
the Senate voted 97 to 2 to approve the
sanctions Republicans Mike Lee and Rand
Paul voted against approving those
sanctions even Ted Cruz and [ __ ] Mitch
McConnell Freudian slip guys Mitch
McConnell excuse me uh Wow we have to
just continue right I mean let's yes
keep go up we'll edit that out don't
worry about it maybe the most important
element of this is that it takes away
the authority from Donald Trump to
unilaterally remove the sanctions that
President Obama put in place and that's
a really good thing NBC News on June
12th 2017 reported that quote in a
rebuke to the president negotiators
agreed that the additional sanctions on
Russia would prohibit the president from
being able to lift them without
congressional approval in addition the
measures would the measure would codify
existing sanctions and place new
economic restrictions in an effort to
economically harm specific individuals
and Russia's economy but what will
happen in the house unclear the house is
much more sympathetic to Trump in the
Senate right now the smart move by House
Republicans would be never even vote on
this because if you vote on it and
you're against it
you're putting yourself on the record as
being against Russian sanctions so if
the house is not interested in this pad
their smartest move is never even bring
up the matter in the first place well at
least we are reaching consensus that
Russia did indeed hack the election and
yes that's what that's step one
even though 17 of our national
intelligence agencies even though Trump
himself admits that Russia did hack the
election there's still people like Roger
stone and others who deny that and then
from that you have to say well if Obama
put the sanctions in place because of
something that we now believe to be true
why is it that we want to remove the
sanctions it doesn't really make sense
so the Senate doing the right thing will
it make a difference in the end
I don't know today's episode of a David
Pakman show is made possible in part by
Warby Parker eyeglasses Warby Parker
recently did the right thing and ditched
advertising on right-wing conspiracy
website Breitbart pulling their ads off
and you can get the free five-day home
Tryon from Warby Parker check out their
glasses I use them when I'm not wearing
contact lenses I started with the free
at-home trial they send you five pairs
of glasses you see which ones you like
you send them back and whichever one you
pick they will put your prescription in
too I like this because I can actually
show the glasses to other people and not
have to just decide on the spot like in
an eyeglass store the eyeglass industry
is controlled by very few corporations
that keep the prices very very high even
over $300 for prescription glasses with
Warby Parker they start at just 95 bucks
mine cost that including lenses and for
every pair sold they give a pair to
someone in need so to try the five pairs
and support the David Pakman show go to
Warby Parker trial comm /t DPS